I mean so your name is so unit/units
madellaine madellaine yeah oh my parents
are hippies and my lovin very hippies we
would eat from the garden my parents are
vegans very crazy little little cookies
but they my dad wanted to name me street
which if we can just imagine for a
second a poor a little like six year
olds in elementary school like gonna go
walk down the street today like people
would make so many jokes about it well
I'm a kid I named my kid River so was
like no we have to do lame like Lane on
the road madellaine Street so that was a
good compromise you know I love your
name and I think it separates you out I
think Madeleine is beautiful enough but
madellaine is it's gorgeous
thank you swells does Kelly possible a
lot of pot a lot of odd jobs here in LA
I did as well and I'm inter after high
school yeah what were what we would ask
you but okay you can ask me first six
years ago I would go knock on people's
doors and like try to sell them new
windows Oh knocking their windows I was
a projectionist at the malibu cinema
wait you were 13 years old yeah I know
it was chilly child labored and but i
but I put the reels on in the wrong
order
Oh like my jobs to put literally thread
the projector but man you screw that up
you definitely run the film it was over
yeah exam I think you know what maybe
I'll just be in movies yeah it was a
better train I feel I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this